the google glass smart slacks have been
in the news recently and not just for
good reasons for shift IT innovators
giulianat sri lanka hit the streets of
berlin to chest out a pair the high tech
I where is officially on sale only in
the US and Britain and costs around
twelve hundred euros that's the stratus
extremely restricted field of vision is
irritating at first on the other hand
it's absolutely fascinating to be able
to record what you're seeing it's like
making a video of my life you once for
as long as the battery lasts at least
they were maybe that awkward similar
sized the google glass power supply is a
big negative another downside is data
privacy wearers can secretly take photos
or even films of strangers activities
for that reason why illegal in the US
they may not be worn in cinemas
restaurants and other public places
juliana found a wide spectrum of
opinions on the issue younger people are
interested a small number said straight
out they didn't want to be filmed I
could imagine the wearer getting into
trouble in certain situations
fortunately that didn't happen to me
Yvonne hofstetter is a legal expert on
artificial intelligence meant as a long
list of reasons why the technology is
problematic in Germany they are gay
[ __ ] they have what outside anyone who
records what I'm saying or takes a
picture of me and potentially posts it
online is breaking German law this is an
intellectual property issue here at Lisa
there are a number of legal stipulations
that the device does not comply with Kim
kesla is a consultant for companies
intending to use the wearables he
conducted a survey as part of his
doctoral thesis on the influence of
smart specs on society exact I don't
think society is ready yet for wearables
like smart specs they do have very
specific uses but they're not of any
great help in everyday life and for now
at least that also applies to clothes
like these with built-in solar panels
but there certainly is potential and
wearables a necklace that serves as an
air filter is one idea another is
clothes that respond to an observer zine
smartwatches are already a reality
they're compatible with smartphones and
boast a number of different features
these days all major consumer
electronics brands have smartwatches in
their range
back to Giuliana solanke in Berlin she
has sessions with her personal trainer
twice a week constantly accompanied by
her fitness tracker it tracks her pulse
monitors her movements and calculates
how many calories she's expanded a
smartphone app enables her to analyze
the resulting data including how she
sleeps for micah's a stem woody for me
it's a motivator but it also helps me to
know myself better I find out more about
my body's behavior and that's something
I can then work on for the future that's
kind of done him yet and then put it so
confident fitness trackers catered to a
growing need among young people to rate
and optimize themselves so even though
my second of people like checking
themselves out and these things address
that egoistic that's the sneaky thing
with these online giants they encourage
us to wear things that provide them with
data the big issue here is our data
that's what they're interested in
wearables do provide some benefits for
users but also for the companies behind
the technology and they show how the
issue of data privacy often falls by the
wayside shift says who's watching who
here